ADRENALINE HIGH. LOOK AT THAT Q.
WE AIN'T ON THE BOARD YET
OUTSIDE OF HER EARLY SECONDS LA
SHOT.
>> O A
LITTLE BIT OF A MOMENT TO GET
READY AND UNDERSTAND JUST TO
>> OH THERE'S PERK.
HE CAN HEAR US.
WE CAN HEAR
BIT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WATCH THE
SPIN MOVE. TEAM IN
CELEBRITY --
>> BUT I THINK --
NG ON THAT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEM I'M NOT GO
NOT TO TAKE
BASKETBALL PLAYER AT THAT SUPPOD
TO BE WITH --
>> -- I'M IT IS --
>> MIGHT NEED MAYOR JUSTIN BIBB.
SHOW TALKING
I'VE
>> I THINK TOWN HALL IS ONE OF
LOOK AT THE BEHIND THE BACK MY
>> DEARICA HAMBY WAS NOT OWN.
OKAY, KAREEM. WOODEN.
ISMS.
HE'LL COME OVER HERE
OUR DEFENSE IS
SHOOTERS GET THEIR SHOT.
>> THAT WORKS TOO.
>> WAIT. -- COACH.
--TO SEE YOU, AND YOU FEED
MIGHT HAVE MORE THAN THAT.
>> HE TRIED IT.
>>
APPLAUSE FOR YOUR CELEBRITY